I'm dr. mark Colquitt I'm a bariatric
surgeon at the Fort Sanders Center for
bariatric surgery it's located at Fort
Sanders Regional Medical Center my
practice is Foothills weight loss
specialist and premier Surgical
Associates we often recommend robotic
bypass surgery for our patients we have
diabetes and other severe ailments of
severe obesity we have an animated video
available that we'd like to show you now
it's meant to educate the patients and
the families if you suffer from severe
obesity and have been unable to lose
weight we may recommend robotic gastric
bypass surgery your digestive system or
gastrointestinal tract includes your
mouth esophagus stomach small intestine
and large intestine
your pancreas liver and gallbladder
squirt digestive juices into your small
intestine to help break down the food
you eat we may recommend bariatric
surgery if you're unable to lose weight
and keep it off through diet and
exercise alone have a body mass index or
BMI above 40 have a BMI above 35 and you
have a life-threatening condition such
as heart disease or diabetes or weigh
more than 100 pounds over your ideal
body weight or ibw gastric bypass
surgery helps you lose weight by
bypassing your stomach and some of your
small intestine to redirect the path of
the food through your digestive system
this stimulates various digestion
hormones that attach themselves to
receptors in your brain and result in
decreasing your appetite and burning
more calories before your procedure and
intravenous line will be started this
allows antibiotics to be given through
the IV to decrease your chance of
infection also gentle anesthesia
medications will be given through this
IV a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and down your throat
to help you breathe
during the operation I will make a small
incision near your belly button and
insert a plastic - called a port carbon
dioxide gas will be pumped into your
abdomen through this port the gas will
inflate your abdomen giving us more room
to see and move the surgical tools after
your abdomen is inflated a
high-definition camera will be inserted
into this port I will make additional
port incisions for robotic instruments
as well as for instruments used by
surgical assistants
an assistant will insert all the robotic
tools through this port unlike standard
laparoscopic instruments these tools can
rotate 360 degrees and have more
flexibility than the human wrist seated
and it's special console will operate
the robotic arms and the camera with
joystick like controls and foot pedals a
computer will translate the exact
movements of my fingers into precise
movements of these surgical tools at the
same time a high-definition vision
system will provide a magnified
three-dimensional stereoscopic view of
the surgical area to perform the gastric
bypass procedure we will divide the
stomach creating a small upper portion
called a pouch this remaining lower
portion of the stomach remains in place
the small intestine will be then cut and
the lower section of your small
intestine will be attached to the
stomach pouch then I reattached the
upper section of your small intestine to
a different part of your lower small
intestine which will allow digestive
juices from your pancreas liver and
gallbladder to help digest your food at
the end of the procedure the tiny
incisions will be closed with stitches
and surgical glue
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed and you will be taken to
the recovery room for monitoring you'll
be given pain medication as needed you
may continue receiving antibiotics
through your IV most patients are
released from the hospital by one to two
days